[Music]
[Applause]
hey everybody welcome to channel
awesomes orbit report your source for
everything happening around the world of
entertainment and pop culture i'm
heather ruse and i'm Ayano aid and this
week we're coming to you from Chicago's
Wizard World how exciting we're super
excited to be here this week a whole
bunch of things came out the first thing
was the defenders and I don't know about
you guys but I was stoked so excited to
watch the defenders it's been getting
some really good reviews so far it's out
there on Netflix if you haven't checked
it out and you're a fan of the Marvel
Netflix universe what are you doing go
check it out check it out right now
there's some really satisfying scenes in
it some really funny good chemistry
between some of the actors I would
highly recommend that you go check it
out no Heather would you recommend
people watch the other series like
Jessica Jones Luke Cage and iron fist
before watching it it's obviously
daredevil it is good to have some of the
background knowledge so yes if you
haven't had a chance yet to check out
iron fists or any of the other Netflix
shows it is better if you see those
first so just spend your whole weekend
watching all of them your own quality
television mostly plenty to binge in
case you run out of things to vent you
can head on over to Amazon Prime where
the tick was just released I watched all
the episodes it goes by very fast and
it's very very funny and entertaining
and was really lovely to watch it it
brought back some nostalgia of watching
the old series ready when they played
the game spoon - yeah so definitely
check it out over on
I'm also on Netflix this week the
live-action Death Note movie premiered
and it's been getting some reviews and
they're getting good Iran um they've
been a little mixed I think some diehard
fans of the show or a little
disappointed in the way that it was
adapted I personally haven't gotten a
chance to check it out yet honestly I'm
a little reluctant because I was a fan
of the series so I will just have to see
you know have past your own judgement
let us know in the comments if you
watched it what you thought of it or if
it's kind of hard to get through
[Laughter]
moving on to some trailers that dropped
this week first and foremost we saw some
new footage for the black mirror also
coming out on Netflix season four we saw
the names of as well as a couple of
clips from all six episodes that are
going to be coming to Netflix soon I
believe season 3 is when it started
being the Netflix exclusive show cry
yeah yeah so that's I think Lee I just
finished season 3 and it was amazing and
heartbreaking as usual so I am
definitely stoked for this season 4 for
sure also trailer that dropped was
American Horror Story cult black so it
seems like it's gonna be just as
mind-bending is all the other seasons
and there's some interesting new casting
like lena Dunham's in it I saw Evan
Peters is supposedly going to be a few
different cult leader ya know so I'm
very interested to see where this goes I
always like the way I've been Peterson
plays the stuff in American Horror Story
so I like American Horror Story so I'm
excited to see it as well it'll be fun
the BBC it just came out with a trailer
for strike the Cuckoo's calling which if
you don't know is a part of a mystery
series that JK Rowling wrote so it just
premiered in the BBC on August 27th on
BBC one and they're a series of murder
mystery novels strike is kind of like a
detective he's an ex-military guy now is
it
active so there's going to be a
miniseries with all of his cases to
solve here it's still unclear what's
happening with it in the u.s. HBO has
some rights to it so we'll just gonna
have to wait and see over here in the US
when it's coming to us we're still not
sure some other things we're looking
forward to is the casting notices we
just got this media David Tennant is
supposedly coming back for Jessica Jones
season 2 so I'm hoping they're
definitely just flashbacks otherwise
[Music]
speaking of David Tennant he was also
cast in Good Omens which is going to be
a miniseries as well
he was cast along with Michael Sheen for
this miniseries and they're the only two
people so far that I've been cast so we
have no idea much about this right now
we'll just have to see yeah
and then also Starfire was cast this
week right yes Starfire who is a part of
the Titans live-action TV series um was
cast Anna do is on 24 legacy was cast as
Starfire so now we know the ladies we
honor Raven we got our Starfire we're
gonna see all the gentlemen on the show
that's right Beast Boy what up still
don't know if it's gonna be Beast Boy or
if there's going to be cyborg as a part
of this as well yeah I'm really looking
excited I'm really looking forward to
seeing who else we get to see as being
cast in tight knees yes
also we heard this week that Punisher
just cast sure a Aghdashloo so we're
hoping that she's not just a cameo yeah
so maybe we'll see a little bit more
content for her I don't know I feel like
casting someone that incredible and just
having a cameo is not worth it you gotta
use your right so hoping to see some
good stuff from her
next up we wanted to go into movie news
Alamo Drafthouse that's right
the the Alamo Drafthouse is having a
clown only screening of it on September
9th they just added a couple more
screenings because of popular demands
and they will be also holding a
pre-party with face painters to touch up
your clown makeup any case yes
smudge it for some terrifying reasons
I'm just gonna keep shaking my head no
because that is just all the note for me
I know a lot of people were upset about
the Wonder Woman only the for the women
only for the Wonder Woman screening so I
know a lot of you non clowns might be
upset right now but it's okay I'm sure
you can see it just the same yeah just
wear some makeup yeah you'll fit right
in
also on Tuesday we heard big news about
a Joker origins movie that's going to be
produced by Martin Scorsese of all
people so it's going to be completely
separate apparently from the current
Jared Leto Joker it's going to be an
elsewhere old story set in the 80s kind
of gritty crime which seems like it's
right up Scorsese's alley but we were
curious what you all thought about this
because what is going on with the DC
Universe I don't know so let's see what
you guys have to say about the new Joker
movie coming out
[Music]
hey guys we're here Wizard World Chicago
right outside the cinema snob
Brad's booth and we're gonna talk to
some people see what they're gonna watch
this weekend what they're gonna watch in
the fall and talk about that new Joker
project that we heard about earlier this
week jinkies I'm feeling a little weird
about it you know there's a lot of Joker
hype recently in the last you know seven
eight years honestly I think you could
choose another character to make a movie
about I've been walking around the con
asking all the Joker's that I see not to
make the film it's it's hard to tell at
this point with anything VC related yeah
I mean I'm curious to see what it is but
the challenge with Warner Brothers has
always kind of been and DC Comics
they've never had a definitive Joker
origin they tried to do that in The
Killing Joke and then it was kind of
wrecked conned away a little bit so I'm
curious to see them actually commit to
something as an origin story if it's
martin scorsese awesome it's either
gonna be the Joker it takes up a job as
a taxi driver and saves a hooker or he's
doing blow on Wall Street he's gonna be
kicking a guy to death cuz he didn't
shine his shoes I was not a huge fan of
the Joker from the Suicide Squad movies
I don't know what like cuz Jared
Leto talks a lot in interviews about
what he was gonna do with the character
and some of the stuff that he was doing
off screen that was helping him to
prepare for it which sounded way more
interesting than what we actually got on
screen like imma put this international
what would over exaggerate a bad bad boy
I try to stay positive so next question
is flash and Supergirl coming out fall
then I super-powered Dawson's Creek
stranger things season 2 is gonna be
super exciting when that hits on
Halloween I love that they announced
that they're only gonna do four seasons
of this show I love the first season I
can't wait to see where they go with
this in the next season the flash I'm a
huge fan of that show you know the third
season kind of went downhill a little
bit for me but I loved a lot of the
stuff that they're announcing for season
four I know the new ducktales recently
came out I really want to check that out
and there I've been seeing bits and
Clips and pieces of the new Mega Man
cartoon I am a huge megaman fan but
looking at the early screenshots it gets
me a little cringy but I'm still gonna
give it a chance because I was told that
the guys behind Ben 10 were the people
that did it
so I'm like you know what I love Ben 10
I'll take a look yes rose hands coming
back
maybe I'm curious right and I like I
like the idea of the Inhumans I like
what Marvel's kind of been building up
through agents of shield with the
Inhumans and I like the direction that
they're kind of trying to take the
Inhumans within the Marvel comic book
universe so I'm curious to see whether
or not that translates to the small
screen or not probably I'll give it I'll
give it a shot like usually with me it's
sort of like I had a day off today would
it be the first thing I land on when I
scroll through here here I've been
seeing from clips that looks amazing I
want to check it out so bad I've been
watching
agents of shield and they've had
Inhumans on them for a while I can't
wait
frightened humans to come god no it
looks like NCIS shot on IMAX hard
everyone thanks for chatting with us a
special shout out to Brad and Velma
Tamra and Trevor for having the time to
chat with us we really appreciate it and
always love talking with you guys
awesome well I think that's gonna be all
from us here how they reckon people find
you on social media you can find me on
Twitter at Heather ruse or Instagram @h
ruse awesome and then you can find me at
facebook at Ayanna wave easy to find or
everywhere else as awesome ayala so
that's gonna be it from us here we're
gonna go enjoy the rest of the con or
show I know we will catch you next week
beam us up
[Applause]
you